[Music]  lion bleep bear monster come here angry  fanfare I'm a demon on Stratis mistake  of your life we didn't even kiss you we  all got it okay all off you're up okay  so much easier now that I can read  lightning round  boys against girls I'm ready I'm ready  go unicorn ice cream castle oaken teapot  Mouse oh I don't think Olaf should get  to rearrange this is it  everyone ready the past is not what it  seems  you must go north find the truth I'm  going with the honor no excuse me I  climb to the North Mountain survived a  frozen heart and saved you from my  ex-boyfriend so promise me we do this  together okay  I promise  need to find the answers about the past  I believe us more than anyone or  anything  frozen - it's a hole putting on some  mortal danger gonna be a regular thing  rated PG tickets available now  [Music]